hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the machine some people
complain that my hello everybody was a
bit to buy in your face right at the
beginning them soon so I tried to make
it soft and sultry anyway someone also
mentioned that the rock was available
right near the wall ah looks like a loaf
of bread puppet - that was some rock
anyway finally alright
ah it's a skull not scary you know weird
noise up tinderbox
I wish oh I'm running out of oil gah
okay I don't know what I came in the
sewer for but I imagine oh it's that um
it's the UH the blue glowy doodad that I
saw before let's see here
Oh sewers are never gonna do
ah here we go here it is
yeah okay I'm guessing emerald gem
that's one of the things on the list
okay that's not a ladder
hahaha you can't fool me oh it's dark
it's dark
huh huh huh huh huh
yeah that's what I thought here we go
and there we go I'm out whoopty-doo all
right I went in there I got the stuff in
here and I think that's everything
that's available I'll be here but
monster was down there okay I got that I
got the bulk of the blood back to face
mr. monster got a barrel not as good as
a chair but it'll do ah Oh text haha I'm
getting a little jumpy
hello who's there hmm got a rock full
and threw in here in a hurry
no [ __ ] a few good oh okay he was right
there huh oh okay
oh okay I got the ingredients huh a
blood a blood a blood one thing i loove
piece of evil in an emerald gem and I
need the Bible aw crap where did I drop
the Bible it was from up above aw crap I
tossed it over the edge
why did I just toss it over the edge I
mean oh I'm such an idiot
oh crap
ah ha ah ha ha ah okay put the Bible in
the center like so
there is something missing okay
I'm guessing the thing of pure evil is
this guy hey about it go there Oh make
me some slow ah God so heavy
lose some weight you think without your
arms and legs it wouldn't be so bad but
nope oh there we go
well don't get nice and situate actually
you'll face up just cuz I don't know why
I want you to be comfortable
well I sacrificing all right okay jar
full of blood
plop this down right shot nope not that
one careful Oh blood there we go okay
now what goes here picture of Nina nope
wrong one
Arnold M nope this must be for the
Emerald M get out there that's not your
spot picture Nina there we go
shut up
ha there we go
almost got it and then I step in with
the Bible the note let me check the
actual note and Italy uh gets I carry a
Holy Bible okay so let me make sure that
I actually carry
ah
huh what sure it was it was not here's
my wife
what
was that it did I get up did I do it
haha I'm just above like boom I'm like
what happened
oh all right um let me actually hang on
let me see if I can what I want to see
maybe because I wasn't actually holding
the Bible when I went in
maybe that cost something elbow see if
not I'm just gonna cut it out and then
cut to the end but I want to see I
wanted to be just in case because if it
is I don't know where it's gonna drop me
for the autosave
it's too far back
that's good hmm come on
ah no okay all the way back here hmm
all right um yeah you know what that's
okay I don't think I don't feel the need
I think that's I think that's okay
maybe it's not maybe it's not maybe
maybe there is something that needs to
happen so oh good sir what stop what get
you son of a your mother
ah yeah that's more like it
okay so just Fred I'm gonna figure this
out because I know I have a good feeling
that that I did something wrong or not
Marty not who knows because I wasn't
holding the Bible and it didn't seem
like a P that in the end that I got my
soul was kind of not good they don't get
a happy ending where I get my wife on my
lovely wife Nina mmm or maybe not or
maybe I'm just wasting all of your time
but I don't care it's going to happen
anyway
oh it's so scary Oh too dark dark dark
sewer Oh climbing up a rope ladder rope
ladders are real things they do exist
but this is not a ladder
this is a rope but good job I guess on
making a rope into a ladder
okay that was everything that up here I
got everything and then I got a run over
here and then I'll send Oh monster no
don't I like you
hello thank you don't I like you are you
there you are
nope nope what happened to you did you
just like disappear okay anyway I'm
gonna try this again
I think I think he thanketh think of
thought think of Thor ba take a sorbet
coming good do but Billy come here Billy
there we go put that get that blown out
of here to get that blown out of here no
Bo night is for you okay and then the
jar like a look here and then a little
crystal goes here and then the on the no
that's not right and the pictures are
here yeah whatever shut up I've got a
Bible Biblia
I've got it what gun oh I had the Bible
I don't think this is gonna change
anything
hello guys how you doing huh oh no it
was a dream okay I guess the ending
didn't change so all right okay so
that's the end all right that was pretty
good pretty good for a custom story I
liked a lot of the the innovative
changes that they made I mean a lot of
obviously amnesia is restricted by its
mechanics but still pretty good if you
have to play one I would recommend it uh
that last chase the first time it
actually got me
anyway ah come on why do you have to
have music at the end it's a total
copyright issue
oh but anyway thank you everyone for
sticking with me through that um that's
all I got to say thank you guys so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next part bye bye